STEPHEN CARPENTER: So we have
heard from the introductions
and the backgrounds
of the people
sitting around the table,
their numerous interests
and numerous starting
points or ways
to connect to issues of water,
of community, of access.
And so the range of
disciplinary interests
I find quite fascinating.
And in terms of
the work that I've
been doing with
curriculum, it really
speaks to this notion
of interdisciplinarity,
and some folks use the
term transdisciplinarity.
But in some ways, when we're
interested in key issues,
social issues, those
disciplines go away.
It's about people.
It's about something beyond
science or beyond art
or beyond whatever that
discipline might be.
So our multiple
areas of expertise
really come into play
quite nicely here.
This year, not only
do I have the pleasure
and the good fortune to be
able to visit three times here
at MIT as a visiting artist.
But I'm also a visiting
artist and visiting
learner at a local
elementary school back home.
And essentially,
people were asking
me, what are you doing at MIT?
And what are you doing
at the elementary school?
And I said, I'm
doing the same thing.
Yeah.
And the key is I'm going--
I want to know at the
elementary school,
specifically, what they can
teach me about what I think
I know about what I'm doing.
And that's what
we're doing here too.
I'm eager to learn about
what you can teach me
about what I think I'm
doing, but also what
we can teach each other, what
we can learn from each other.
Quite often, in some
educational spaces,
administrators,
teachers, other folks
in various levels
of making decisions
forget, explicitly or
otherwise, that learners
bring knowledge with them to
every single learning context.
So there's as much learning
going on in one direction
as there are in
multiple directions.
So we all have valuable
information to share.
So I'm eager to have
that conversation.
So it's about the
filters, right?
It's about how these ceramic
water filters inspire
multiple curriculum
possibilities, not just
a curriculum or
instructional possibilities
for how do you make the filter,
and how do you use them?
But there are other
ripples, pardon the pun.
There are other ways that the
filters might inspire learning.
For example, the
filters are designed
to sit inside a plastic
water receptacle
like the one you see here and
the one you saw in the video.
But what if you asked artists
to create a ceramic receptacle
in their own style if you
gave them the specifications,
and they created the
vessel in their own style?
And then you could
actually have an exhibition
of these receptacles.
And that exhibition could
tour to different locations.
And in doing so, you could
promote the exhibition.
But you could also then talk
about the global water crisis.
You could talk about lack
of adequate access to water.
You could talk about the ways
that artists and other folks
are engaging in work to
respond to these issues.
And so these exhibitions went
on for a number of years.
My colleagues and I were talking
about reviving this practice.
The idea is if someone purchases
one of the receptacles,
that money essentially is
a donation back to a water
project.
This is a vessel that I
created as part of that work.
And it's inspired by
the sanitation workers'
strike in 1968, I Am a Man.
And it relates in
many ways to found
object art, assemblage work from
some of the modernist artists.
That's a top of a trophy I
found at a secondhand store
with a guy with a little fedora.
It was perfect, right?
And I made these little signs.
But the idea being, how
can the work of art itself
function as a way to
speak out and speak back
to social issues?
Inspired by-- this one was
inspired by the water filters
and water filter receptacles.
So those links become entangled.
But they also allow
for other trajectories
of thinking to happen.
Well, we can talk
about protests.
We can talk about, well,
what is a basic human need?
What is a human right?
What is privilege?
What do you need and
what do you want?
Those are two different things.
And I think those kinds of
conversations with students
are quite powerful.
Who has access?
Who sets up the limitations?
What is necessary?
Who takes action?
These kinds of
questions, I think,
are central to not only
a curricula within art
within education, but also
curricula within the various
disciplines that are
represented around this table.
AUDIENCE: I'm
leaving on the 13th
to go to Puerto Rico to
a central mountain town,
Cidra to bring
solar lamps, water
filters, and solar
panels, and solar panel
kits to a certain sector
of a barrio in Cidra.
So the idea of a filter that
fits in a luggage, because I'm
limited to what I can personally
carry-- three 50-pound bags.
And I'm paying $75 for
the third one, two, three,
whatever, to do that, because
the bothersome part for me,
this is not my background.
I don't know.
So we have rechargeable
batteries at home
that we've been very true to.
We only use our
rechargeable batteries.
That's as far as
that goes with us.
And then the filter
water inside it.
But water is basically good.
But seeing all these
shipments of bottled water
and the requests for batteries
in an island and just the
waste that that will create
and that no one thinks about.
And how can at least in
one corner of the world--
or in this case, that island,
can we try to do something?
Because I talk to my family.
And they go to a river, and
that's where they bathe.
And that's where they
get water to clean.
And clean and bathe.
That's it, because
they won't drink it,
because they don't know
if something died further
up the mountain.
And they don't have
access to that.
And then there's sun
everywhere, right?
So just that immediate
thing, and it's
called Sector Bloquera, because
at the bottom of the hill,
there's a huge
hardware type of like--
[SPEAKING SPANISH] just like
a lumber yard type of thing.
I was going to say sawdust.
I'm like, oh, I can easily get--
[LAUGHTER]
--I can get tons of sawdust
from the [SPEAKING SPANISH]..
But yeah, the access and how, in
a limited time frame can one--
as I look at that little
one right there just
to do that, because--
right.
And that weighs nothing.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
It weighs nothing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I guess that's my of this.
And then I see [INAUDIBLE],,
like [INAUDIBLE] Hartford.
I'm from Hartford, so
he has Hartford roots.
And Dred Scott, it's a
really exciting presentation.
And he contextualizes
it really incredibly.
But this really drew me
because of the immediacy
of what's happening out there.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Absolutely, yeah.
Well, what we're seeing in
Puerto Rico right now is just--
for me, it's beyond
words, beyond adjectives.
I can't-- it's indescribable.
I spoke with a colleague, and
friend of mine a few days ago.
His family is in Puerto Rico.
And he says it's--
he talked about-- before we
heard the reports in the news
about the gas issues
and the water issues,
he told me about both of those.
I also appreciate your comment
about sending water bottles
and batteries.
And that just
creates more waste.
It's helpful.
But unless you think
about what happens
beyond the life of
that material, that's
being irresponsible
at some level, right?
So the rechargeable, the
recyclable, the renewable
is important.
Yeah, these little filters
are made from the same mixture
as the large filters.
They're just on a smaller scale.
You see in the
back on that table.
We made some mini
filters yesterday.
We still have some
clay and sawdust.
We can make some more
today if you want.
They would need to be tested
to make sure that they
have the proper flow rate.
But the other thing is
we have to make sure
that the water that is
there, that these filters
would filter out the bad stuff
in the water that's there, OK?
So I'm happy to make some
small filters, if you'd
like to take some with you.
And you'd have to see.
But you also need to
take some test kits.
And I have some test kits.
If I don't have them
here, I can get them.
We can get them to you.
But the idea is that you
need to test the water.
It would be equally
irresponsible to say,
oh, here's something to take
with you and it doesn't work.
So we have to figure
out what's in the water.
And that's the basis for setting
up the filter facilities.
But the idea of being
able to take some of these
in your backpack
and on your carry-on
and being able to distribute
it and have immediate response,
that's a big deal.
And so what you're
up to and the work
that you're going to be
doing is very important.
But these things
are fragile too.
So the packing
that it would take
would require taking
up some space as well.
So there's always give
and take, push and pull.
I was talking to
someone yesterday
about a very similar
part of the conversation.
And one of things we started
to do when I was at Texas A&M,
before I moved to Penn
State, was revolving
around this very thing.
And we thought, you know what.
May I borrow your bottle
for just a second?
This opening is about the
same size as larger bottles.
I don't have one here,
so like a liter bottle.
What if we turned it over,
and you cut it right here?
Or you cut it just enough that
you could have a little flap,
all right?
And then what if we took the
same material, and instead
of what some folks are
doing with making disks--
they look like hockey pucks that
you can put inside PVC piping--
what if we made little corks?
They look like
little wine corks,
but it's made out
of this material.
That could fit into this bottle.
So you lift the hinge.
You put the cork down there.
And then we have our own
little portable receptacle.
So it would take this
bottle that then gets
discarded that creates waste.
Maybe it becomes a
repurposed individual?
Yeah, you're just creating cork.
How many wine corks could
you take in your backpack?
Hundreds, right?
So it's that notion of scale
and responsibility and access
and immediacy.
Maybe after a couple
of weeks or maybe
in this case, unfortunately,
a couple of months,
there would not be that need.
And you'd have ways to
deal with the recycling.
But anyway, what
you're talking about
is a very important issue
and set of concerns.
I first became familiar with
the term "creative disruption"
from David Darts, who
is an art educator,
and his doctoral
dissertation and work looking
at the practice of culture
jamming, which grows out
of an entire practice
of responding
to capitalism and advertising.
So David looked at this idea
of visual culture jamming,
where you add--
instead of looking at
culture-specific broadly--
visual culture, more
specifically, and the way one
might look at the visual
components of a culture
differently through
some sort of what
he called creative disruption.
Creative meaning,
his sense, coming
from an artistic or cultural
production perspective,
but yeah, you can be disruptive.
One might argue, you know, any
kind of disruption is creative.
But certainly, the
creative in this sense
comes from a more generic
notion of artistic or cultural
production.
AUDIENCE: How many decades
ago, approximately, for that?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: About one.
[LAUGHS] Well, no, yes, the
term is about 15, 20 years old,
in the sense that I
understand it to be.
AUDIENCE: It's been
a very popular term
in business management.
Harvard Business
School, they've been
teaching courses in
creative destruction
as a strategy for
entrepreneurship.
So if you want to take
on the big companies,
you need to do something that
disrupts the whole logic of how
whatever that service or product
is is organized and presented.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Part of the work
that I do at my
current university
and previous universities
in art education
is to prepare teachers of
art, but even K-12 teachers.
And so with that
preparation, there
are methods courses or
curriculum development courses
that essentially are structured
to respond in many ways
to very specific
skills or content.
And that's all fine
and good, except, what
I find more interesting
are the questions
that emerge that can be
center points for curriculum.
So instead of thinking
of curriculum development
and management, it's the idea
of theorizing curriculum.
So spinning it around in
terms of the questioning, most
teacher preparation programs
that I'm familiar with,
because there are
these standards
and points for
accreditation, students
must meet specific responses.
And they're pretty
rigid, those curricula.
But I think that there are
ways to play in and around.
I've worked this
way for a while.
Around, by still responding
to those expectations
for certification,
but at the same time,
open it up so that
teachers become
knowledgeable and prepared
and have experience
to have an ongoing engagement
with learning and developing
interesting and
exciting curricula that
responds to social practices.
For
Example, the idea of focusing
on a theme or a concept
or a question, rather than on
a specific outcome or skill.
Just making that shift is a big
challenge for a lot of teacher
preparation programs,
because what you're doing
is you're essentially saying,
the predetermined content
that we have and the
predetermined skills
that we have is not all
there is to our discipline,
that there could be more to it.
And it also suggests that it's
not really the idea of learning
that's important in education.
It's about teaching content.
So I like to turn also
the shift from teaching
to learning, to making the
project about learning.
And so this is how I'm going
about it myself, Larry,
working with undergrads
and grad students
to put questions at the
center of their curriculum.
So it becomes an
inquiry-based approach.
Or it becomes a
thematic approach.
And often, it's inspired
by social issues.
I can show you an
example or two,
if you'd like, and
specifically to water.
So one of the things that
I've enjoyed doing is using--
we've had a back and
forth, Larry, about access
to education in broad spaces.
Online is one way
that that happens.
So MindMeister is
a free application.
And so my early work in
curriculum theorizing
and development looked
at spatial hypertext.
So what if you took
a concept like--
and more than a concept.
I mean, water is a
broad idea, a big--
so what if we put water
at the center here?
And what I did was, I said,
look, at a group of students,
we said, if we put water
at the center, what
are the ideas and questions and
concepts that emerge from just
us thinking about water?
So there might be technology
concerns and issues
related to pollution.
There are contemporary artists
who are looking at and thinking
about water.
There's information then at
the next level that relates
to our understandings of water.
And so what you're seeing
here is an interconnected web
of information inspired by
the simple notion of water.
What if you as a teacher--
you can be a teacher,
you can be an artist,
you can be whatever--
what does water
make you think of?
What questions emerge?
What do you know about water?
What are you curious
about about water?
If you start curriculum
in that place--
what do you know?
What don't you know?
What would be
interesting to know?
And you go off in these
various dimensions.
And you start to
learn along the way.
And you're not doing
it by yourself.
You're learning with
a group of people.
So everyone in class
has access to this web.
Everyone in class,
over the series
of days that we're
working on this,
can see how it continues
to be populated.
And we all have access to
everybody else's information.
This is a curriculum
right here of water
that could be navigated,
that could be--
and again, I'm not showing
you all of the details.
But you could select
certain components of it,
highlight those components.
There might be
some key questions.
You might like
some of the things
that one person looked at.
All right, so here are some
issues about pollution,
sanitation in civilizations.
This piece also allows
us to put embedded video
and other content.
So the idea would be, if
the preparation of teachers
or the work that teachers do
as they prepare to be certified
and licensed moves away, in
my view, from only focusing
on discipline content,
only on discipline skills,
but privileges the questioning
and the nurturing of inquiry
and learning, I
think what we have is
we have a different sensibility.
You have teachers
who aren't limited
by their own disciplines
and are seeking ways
to make those connections.
And in doing that,
a curriculum that
comes from this
mode of development
can then respond to any state
or local standards of learning,
any national
curriculum concerns.
The example I want to show you--
you ever been to an
elementary art exhibit,
and you see all of the
images look very similar?
You see all the paintings
and the drawings, whatever.
Rarely, do we see art criticism.
Rarely, do you see
young children's art
historical papers on display.
It happens every
once in a while.
This is a water filter display
at the Chesterfield County
Exhibition.
So this is just one teacher.
Sean Collins did this.
And so he used the water filters
as part of his curriculum
but also as part of
the art exhibition.
He got comments from
teachers, like, wow, what?
How does this-- art?
This is part of
your art curricula?
Well, yeah, why not?
This is what we're doing.
And he linked it to Greek vases.
And he linked it to
expressionist painting.
He linked it to all sorts
of other components.
But by making the art curriculum
or the space in which an artist
might think inclusive of
appropriate technology
and social issues and
social responsibility,
that's a disruption right there.
So can elementary kids do it?
Absolutely, they can.
This is a page from
the Reservoir Studio,
including names of
the art teachers
who have agreed to work
with me or found interest
or that have invited me to
do water filter performances
but also work on
curricula with them.
And this list keeps growing.
I haven't updated it yet.
But I have several others
who have been interested.
Here's a person who came to a
curriculum conference, Denise
Gordon.
She was a science
educator in Texas.
She came to this curriculum
and pedagogy conference.
And instead of
presenting a paper
on the water filters, my
colleague, my mentor Richard
Wukich and I, we set up a water
filter production facility.
And we made filters as our
conference presentation.
And so people coming in
expecting to see a paper
presented, they helped
me sift sawdust.
And [CHUCKLES] we
made the filters.
The reason I'm telling you that
is because Denise Gordon showed
up to that presentation.
And she said, I am
a science teacher,
but I think in these
interdisciplinary ways.
And I like these experiential,
hands-on approaches.
And so I sent her four
mini-filters at her request,
two that had silver embedded
in them and two that did not.
And her advanced
science students,
middle school students, did
tests on those water filters.
They tested the water
from two local sources.
They did research on the
production of the filters.
And they set up--
they found other
commercial filters,
and they ran the results.
And they found that
these little filters
worked as well or better than
those commercial filters on two
different sources of water.
One was, I think,
the local river.
And the other was some
other sewage space.
But my point is that she
empowered her students
to take control and
to lead the inquiry.
And this is middle school.
So can middle school
students think in these ways
and consider their place in the
world and their responsibility?
Absolutely.
And again, these are just
two of many possible ways
that this might happen.
But just responding
specifically to that question.
AUDIENCE: How do we
place for the disruptive
way of doing things
and incremental way
of doing that thing?
Probably what is existing,
taking it ahead and improving
on it may be quite incremented
and disruptive where
you put a full stop and
start with something new.
In fact, ceramic
filter itself, I
don't know whether to
call it disruptive,
because a filter existed.
And it was modified
in some ways.
So I'm really confused
about these definitions
about disruptive, incremental.
What is it?
And how do you go
back, especially
in terms of disasters,
where I think the need is
to go back to basics?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: For me,
disruption is incremental.
It's a process.
It's a verb in my thinking.
Certainly one can disrupt
with a specific action.
And it seems like it's only
happening in that moment.
But we can think more broadly
that once that moment happens,
there are continuing
echoes from that.
So I think it's also
site-specific too,
the degree of incremental change
or disruption that happens.
But I don't--
I'm not thinking about
disruption, necessarily,
as one specific moment.
I think of it in a longer term,
in a moving, time-based way.
So that's one part
of your question.
I think the second part
had to do with the filters
and seeing them as disruptive.
And certainly, for folks who
didn't have adequate access
to clean water and now
they might have access,
the filters have disrupted
that previous narrative
of inaccessibility,
and have disrupted
a longstanding-- a
generational experience
with being sick
and having disease.
So it's disrupting that health
issue and that human issue.
And so there's that.
And then going back
to basic, absolutely.
I mean, you do what
you need to do.
And certainly, the
water's coming down.
Let's get some plastic
and collect the water.
I mean, that seems like the
most appropriate technology
that we've talked about today.
I think your examples
are right on.
And I hope it clarified
a little bit how
I'm thinking about
disruption, not as an idea.
I didn't clarify-- disruption
for me is not a moment.
But it's an ongoing--
AUDIENCE: It's a continuum.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: It's
a continuum, absolutely.
Yeah.
And it's variable.
AUDIENCE: It was my job too.
I mean, it's a job
for us to do that.
So even though it's
disruptive or not disruptive,
my job is to provide clean
water to people out there.
And that's what I'm doing.
[CHUCKLES] So whether
it is disruptive or not,
it's that simple.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Well, yeah, it is.
Yeah, yeah, and I
think sometimes I
like to be a bit more dramatic,
maybe, than necessary.
[LAUGHTER]
And to think more
broadly or differently,
folks didn't have the water.
And you allow water
to be available.
You disrupted their
lack of access, so--
AUDIENCE: I think I did my job.
[CHUCKLES]
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
You did your job.